[Music]
in Satan's oohing news one some damn
Satan is suing not you could sue Satan
right Oh see ensuing it was more like
with GOP oh wait
they say ensuing you are you soothing
with yours we're suing Satan okay no
Satan suing us 50/50 shot submitted by
Costco hot dogs sausage - they don't
want sausage anymore yeah yeah but now
they have burgers though it's better
that [ __ ] was not a Polish sausage bro
okay well it tasted are you a Polish
sausage expert I am I'm German bro you
better back up bro is that the same
thing yeah hold these people were polish
it's like the same area I mean by
Germany are you call me Chinese and
Korean the same thing you said it for me
this satanic 10 people really love that
The Satanic temple is planning to sue
after a Netflix series copied its
monument design huh I want to go to the
satanic bus no no because you're coming
back home and I don't like oh that's
right the architectures architects have
copyrights right you can't just bite it
bite off [ __ ] there's a copyright on it
so have you guys heard of the new
Sabrina the Teenage Witch but now it's
called the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina wait is it the same one no she's
at the witch well it's the same witch
but like they kind of changed her up so
now it's like scary not like the one
that we grew up with absolutely possible
darker yeah this one's way creepier
there's like kind of gory they still got
a sarcastic cat right that's right I saw
the first episode and the cat doesn't
speak so I don't know damn what a missed
opportunity to get like Gilbert
Gottfried in there or something
hate his I could love it when he was
like this stop it have you heard Gilbert
Gottfried's normal voice like his normal
talk he has a normal it's [ __ ] crazy
he lost something a normal person right
yeah it's [ __ ] great look up like
Google like a Gilbert Godfried like
normal voice or whatever and he's like
on a radio show recall using oh yeah you
know how's it going like yeah yeah like
kate gilbert godfree's here we love me
is funny and then he's like he's like
he's basically it's like sounds like
he's talking about his taxes yeah he's
like yeah it's it's great but he can
like slide into the voice and then slide
back out yeah thank God I heard that's
like Michael Blackson to like he doesn't
actually have who's uh you black
[ __ ] from Stan a comedian oh
he's an Wathan out now I know he just
okay well okay with no fall plane yeah I
think was I'm still playing he's on the
pilots right he was like he's like super
gaunt looking very skinny African dude
he looks like you got yellow eyes ah
[ __ ] the end the captain no that was
like a legit like oh I'm the captain I
love that guy alright well that's a
great mean old people don't know who
Michael Platt indeed got me now look at
me I'm the captain I love that bit that
was dope yeah better his African accent
isn't even real it's fake cuz like he's
like thin fill yours what someone missed
the lavalava
no Oh Sean Paul no no that fool it
doesn't I love that you did it and I
don't even know what it is saying about
like I don't think it's a you something
guys his mouth full all the time
whatever he's got marbles in his mouth
well we do real this conversation let's
continue anyways you know shaggy as a
former Marine you was yeah interesting
stuff separate Fidelis brother who's
that Semper Fidelis you don't know sever
five four five five carry on that's a
Marine that remodel always it's Latin
okay
always faithful anyway we're talking
about neckflix the show here so they
sure
this is so the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina it's about how Sabrina she's
like a dark witch and like the whole
thing is how they worship Satan and then
she ends up going to this satanic school
or some [ __ ] like for magic school and
then in that magic school they have just
statue of befoe met and befell the film
it film it he's [ __ ] with you know
Baphomet that one I've heard that way
through them I've heard it in remote
parts of Israel kind of like that way oh
I see yeah yeah Israel well they used
the same techniques temples oh yeah that
looks so this is theirs and then this is
the oh wait who's theirs
yeah the real one this is from the
Netflix so it's like obviously very very
similar yes yeah there's no way you just
[ __ ] think about yourself and the
coincidentally looks just like that yes
so you need some things don't
I kinda want to get that tattooed on me
it seems like they were trying to make
it as authentic as they could it's very
very metal well that's the thing like
this
so the Satanic temple it's only been
around since 2012
oh it's brand new it's a brand new [ __ ]
that but that's a good year to do it
like during the mine and the calendar so
their headquarters is in Salem
Massachusetts which is worse it's like
also in Massachusetts where the Sabrina
thing is yeah so what they are it's a
non-theistic theistic religious and
political activist group you said it
right again I don't know I try to yep
yes - I guess so they're saying the bad
whole image of Bethel by foment and
Baphomet definite say it with some
attitude man come on dude it's all made
up anyway neat funny the first one
always the first one always going to say
they should like a [ __ ] I can't have
the confidence you all have in this room
we don't know house really caught fire
right there most of us don't have much
confidence did I know
oh okay yeah yeah I love it but if you
said it with like mad confidence nobody
would have never said [ __ ] if you like
[Laughter]
but if you said it with confidence I
want to fade it out my own explanation
okay that's the Easter labor head just
the same way like how when I yell like
that when I've said it I said it with my
own confidence and it sounded confident
that when you let go you let him cut you
know we did it get that it was cuter
with last I will say did you have your
back a little bit my sugar-free Red Bull
it tastes a little diet e today anyway
so he that this actual character that I
can't say the name it yeah perform it oh
[ __ ] in the Beast
welcome to hell yeah surprise so he's a
DD that the Knights Templar were falsely
accused I'm worshiping and that
subsequently was incorporated into
disparate occult in mystical traditions
so that's the original okay but then the
Satanic temple they added the two kids
looking at him and like certain symbols
and [ __ ] so this is there's like they
copyrighted this and so they're saying
they're gonna be suing Netflix because
they use a similar image and it's also
the way they're using it it's like we
worship Satan and like and then they're
trying to like make people scared of
Satan could they design that statue for
to look friendly yes thank you
yeah go Ted with with the [ __ ] wings
and the he's meant to be welcoming yeah
yeah so he's jacked he also works out
yeah like co-founded the temple the
Satanic temple he tweeted out yes we are
taking legal action regarding hashtag
the chilling adventures of Sabrina
appropriating our copyrighted Monument
designed to promote their assumed
assigning [ __ ] I can't breathe so
asinine passing on a see me signing yo
man you know what [ __ ] ass tonight
Afeni is way I agree it's way it sounds
better defense though like when you're
reading it like you can read it it's
just the trouble now is when you have to
say it out loud cuz you don't know what
it sounds like you know what it you know
what it means and all that [ __ ] but then
what is the most a seeming thing I've
ever heard in my life Jia you're
assuming well you know what that sounds
like it's a signing which would be fun
why are they pissed yeah so this is the
guy that says I using a Sunnah like why
are they trying to make this [ __ ]
scary like right luteum grave cloudy
[ __ ] but he's probably weren't a contact
to man he's probably wondering why
people don't use his name is Lucy in
that's a demonic name yeah but it sounds
like a variation of Lucifer it's a
bummer cuz it's a nice name Lucia yeah I
mean it's like it's Gary's do we name
our second no or Damian
are scary for me because especially cuz
I one movie with a kid omen they just
want honey let's be real man they're not
trying to bend the image about the
church or whatever the [ __ ] like that's
been happening and like the whole reason
why it's appealing is cuz they're like
edgy and [ __ ] so they're like like the
hot topic Church is like nobody from the
[ __ ] 17th century can sue for their
architectural like you know yeah this is
it it's all public domain yeah well I
mean they're saying that they kind of
have to sue because those are like
copyright laws or whatever because I'm
later on if someone else would use it
then it's like well then why didn't you
I thought she liked actually kind of
have to do that but what are they gonna
use this for maybe they could settle
them for some like small amount of money
like Oh give us ten bucks right yeah
this whole thing though is just that the
way that the the Netflix show is
interpreting this whole thing is to
represent something evil and that it
will stir stir fear of his group and
that was the whole the show doesn't do
that the show does no no no I'm just
saying like it's been a known thing that
that you have the good angel on the bad
angel and I mean good [ __ ] luck
they're like Satan's dick is not scarier
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]